Speaker 1: Okay.
I this really should be you know, we have
all these clips on YouTube, 10 million views,
8 million views, 6 million views.
This should really be one of our most viewed
clips ever on YouTube.
I'm not saying it will be, but it should be.
We were on the ground in Texas, Austin, Texas,
this weekend for the Trump event.
Our correspondent Luke Beasley was there.
Luke, this is the second time Luke has done
stuff on the ground for us.
He's doing an incredible job.
You can find his YouTube channel at David
Pakman dot com slash Luke.
That's lucky.
Okay.
We're going to go through some of these clips
of Luke talking to people.
And I mean, just just prepare yourselves.
I don't think we've ever seen anything like
this, this combination of ignorance, delusion,
paranoia, conspiracy, thinking.
Let's just jump right in.
Speaker 6: Playing for the audience.
What that sign is all about.
Speaker 5: What they're saying about open
border.
Yeah.
You know, every country protect their their
their country.
The people by the border in every country
have a border.
Why buy them.
Speaker 1: Up?
And so the sign says Biden, just drop the
bomb on us, the American people.
What can we do now?
Wait until 2024.
What about if we lose again?
So can we do something?
Yes, we can.
The real question is, can you pay the price?
There's some tips then you should be, do I
know, ever give a job to this illegal people
and not ever buy something from them?
Okay.
Anyway, by the way, it's so funny because
corporations keep hiring undocumented immigrants.
The message really shouldn't be to Joe Biden.
It should be to the corporations.
And we've had a justice system in the in the
U.S. for a long time, Republican or Democrat
alike, that they don't really go after the
companies hiring the undocumented immigrants
anyway continue and murder.
Speaker 6: But you understand that at the
border, thousands upon thousands of people
are getting detained every single day and
thousands of people are being deported.
So we're enforcing the border just maybe not
as much as you would like.
Why?
Speaker 5: I don't think 19,000 people is
the border.
I think nobody to deport.
Speaker 1: So so this is an individual who
has been convinced that all deportations have
stopped under Joe Biden.
Obviously, that's not true, but he believes
it.
Speaker 6: Yes, thousands of people are being
deported before go.
Speaker 5: No, no, no.
Speaker 6: Under Joe.
Under Joe Biden.
Speaker 5: We know you're writing.
Na.
Speaker 1: Na, na.
So how do you argue with that?
Na.
There's nobody being deported now.
Well, if you believed that, I could understand
being confused.
But of course, deportations have obviously
continued under Joe Biden.
Next clip.
This is about the election being stolen and
people's feelings about it.
Speaker 6: Runs in 2024 and he loses.
Do you think it'll also be stolen again?
Speaker 7: It could be, possibly, but there's
no way to say that it will be or will won't
be.
Speaker 6: And how will you tell if it is
or is it like, do you think he could just
lose fair and square?
Speaker 1: Beautiful.
Speaker 7: Yeah, he could.
Very possibly.
But I mean, we feel this last election was
rigged and that there are a lot of unknown
voters that have passed.
And how do you vote if you're dead?
Speaker 1: So the dead voter's conspiracy
widely debunked.
Speaker 6: You're saying people used the names
of dead voters?
Yes.
To vote, even though that hasn't been shown
in any of the court cases or anything that's
shown.
But research from whom?
Speaker 7: I'm not exactly sure.
Speaker 1: Research he's not sure about shows
dead people voted.
Speaker 7: And I'd have to ask the person
who told me this and is.
Speaker 1: See, that's a farce.
That's actually a very interesting thing.
I'd have to ask the person who told me this
about the research.
Well, you should have asked that right away.
In other words, this guy accepted it.
Now that Luke is saying, well, what's your
what's your evidence for dead people voting?
He goes, I'd have to ask the person who told
me.
Well, that's what you should do right away.
That's hopefully an instructive moment.
Here is another woman who feels that the election
was stolen from Donald Trump.
Speaker 6: And then 2020.
You think it was stolen from Trump?
For sure.
And what makes you believe that?
I just I believe it when I just spoke here
in Austin, The Register in Austin, Texas,
where I was a chain of states.
And she was laughing at me like a week and
a half before the election.
Speaker 4: Going, ha.
Speaker 6: Ha, this elections are going be
decided.
I was in the car, I had a witness.
I'm a caregiver.
I was driving.
It's like, do you think.
Speaker 1: She had a witness?
Speaker 6: She just meant since Biden was
still ahead in the polls.
No, he was not ahead of our polls.
And no, I mean, like polling cynical and.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Because I bet money was somebody that Biden
will win.
But it wasn't because I had inside information
bill.
Speaker 1: I mean, just beautifully done there
by Luke.
Speaker 4: I don't have inside information.
Speaker 6: It's just a feeling.
Just a feeling and just want to comment.
I mean, just walk around.
Speaker 1: Look around.
The comments she heard while walking around
Austin and her feeling proves to her that
there was a national conspiracy to steal the
election from Trump.
And by the way, she she voted in Texas where
Trump won.
So why would they be talking in Texas where
Trump won?
I mean, none of it makes sense.
Speaker 6: Look around.
The people walk around.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
All right.
So as you can tell, this is extraordinarily
disturbing.
This may be the most interesting clip of all.
Luke speaks to a couple.
Now the guy is wearing an American flag vest,
a backwards American flag T-shirt, and then
the woman with the guy is wearing a save.
What does it say?
I guess it's a Save America dress.
You'll notice that when they realize that
the interview is not going super well, she
whispers to the guy that maybe they should
end this and she walks away.
This is really good work on the ground.
Check this out.
Speaker 6: All right.
I'm here with the best looking people at this
event.
What are you guys hoping to see here at the
the speech?
Speaker 5: Looking for anything that has to
do with election fraud?
We came to see here, Dinesh, in the new movie,
2000 Mules, how to avoid this going forward.
Speaker 1: Imagine being like, I want to figure
out how to avoid fraud going forward.
I'm going to go to an event and listen to
Dinesh D'Souza.
Speaker 5: My recommendation to your whole
audience is everybody needs to take off sometime
in November.
Yeah.
Let's get to every ballot location with video
and stop videotaping this so it doesn't happen
again.
Speaker 6: Okay.
What about you?
And I'm from Philadelphia, Pennsylvania, where
obviously they had 1100 mules.
Speaker 1: There were no mules.
I mean, listen, I learned there were zebras
spotted at some polling places and an occasional
donkey, but there have been no mules whatsoever.
Speaker 6: I just wanted to ask Dinesh, what
is it that we could do differently for the
next election?
Can you imagine?
And obviously, you know, it's really nice
to be around a lot of other patriots.
So here's my question on that.
When I hear people talk about this, I want
to give it the time of day.
But then you look at every official medium
that you would make, you know, prove that
the courts, all those things.
And it's not and it's not like there's not
even people that Trump appointed.
Speaker 1: So this is great.
The woman says the courts are corrupt and
Luke points out a lot of those courts are
run by Trump appointed judges.
The woman has no answers.
She just turns and looks at the guy, literally.
She just gape.
She just white flag and just looks at the
guy.
Speaker 5: QUESTION So the thing is, we all
know that it happens.
Speaker 6: So I don't know that.
Speaker 5: But.
Speaker 6: I don't know that I need evidence
to believe something like that.
Speaker 5: I know.
I know.
So listen, it's this.
How about this?
Social media only seems to censor liberals
because they never talk.
How great Biden.
Speaker 1: Is.
They only seem to censor liberals.
I assume he means conservatives like this
guy.
It's just nothing's making sense.
Speaker 5: 81 million people have yet to see
anything.
Pro-Biden.
How about you?
Speaker 6: I think Biden's done good stuff.
There's some pro-biden stuff like American
Rescue Plan, getting out of Afghanistan, managing
the Russia, Ukraine, war.
Speaker 5: Taxes that is 40 year high.
Speaker 1: Understand taxes at a 40 year high.
Biden hasn't done tax reform.
That's super interesting.
Taxes are biden hasn't done stuff on taxes.
Speaker 5: Given given baby pharma to immigrants
coming over the border, except they our own.
Speaker 6: But on the baby formula thing,
you do understand that that's like .00 1%
of baby formula.
Speaker 5: Are you affected by the day before?
No.
Speaker 6: I'm not.
But if they don't get it, their baby starve.
If Americans here, they can find other ways
to get it.
But they're stuck.
Speaker 5: Detained about the Americans that
are affected.
Speaker 6: And we need to help them as well.
And that's what we're trying to I'm sure they're
trying to do.
Speaker 5: An immigrant.
Speaker 6: Of course, now that they're all
board, like.
Speaker 5: The fact that our tax money goes
to the Ukraine, where it gets laundered back
to these corrupt politicians.
Speaker 1: The tax money goes to the Ukraine
where it gets laundered back.
Speaker 5: What and the myriad media journals
that are all liberal, much like yourself,
you keep on spinning this.
There's no escaping.
He has done nothing.
Right, man?
Speaker 1: This is.
This is much like yourself, kid.
He talked to talk to a guy about the death
penalty.
The guy said the women should be killed.
Women should be killed if they have an abortion.
He I mean, listen, he's for the death penalty.
He believes abortions, murder.
You do the math.
Speaker 6: So big news, Roe v Wade, it looks
like it's going to be overturned.
Yeah.
What was your reaction to that?
Speaker 5: So, no, that's great.
It was horrible, you know, horrible ruling
in the first place.
And all they've done is muddy it up since
then.
So I think it's about time.
Speaker 6: Okay.
And then in your ideal country, what would
the rules of laws be on people getting abortions?
Speaker 5: Everybody has the right to life.
Life starts at conception.
It's science.
You know, this is a human life, okay?
We should protect life always.
Speaker 6: And the punishment if you got an
abortion.
Speaker 5: What do you think?
When you take a life, an innocent life should
be murder.
You're not happy.
Speaker 6: Here.
Oh, it should be murder.
You don't say you should be murdered.
Like, should the person get death penalty?
Yes.
Do you think people should get the death penalty
for having an abortion?
Speaker 5: You know what happens when, say,
for instance, a guy kicks a woman in the in
the stomach, that's he gets a murder sentence
in many states for the death of that while.
Speaker 1: Kill the women who have abortions.
Quite a scene.
And then lastly, here is the there's this
is an interesting thing.
There's lots of folks who are just obsessed
with communism and socialism.
But when you ask them any follow up questions,
they don't know what the hell is going on.
Here's a woman who's very, very angry about
communism.
Speaker 6: At the Trump event.
What are you hoping to see besides Trump?
Just like what you want to hear?
Speaker 4: Oh, because I came from a communist
country and Trump is the one who fight for
America and who's.
Speaker 6: A communist in our country, who's
pushing communism a.
Speaker 4: Go?
I came from a Vietnam.
You know, Vietnam is a communist country now.
And that's why we love Vietnam.
We love it.
Nam by Bible and we we don't like em, you
know, communists.
Speaker 6: I understand not liking communism.
What's the connection to liking Trump.
Speaker 4: As he's a doer?
He he loves everyone and he want to save America
from, you know, the liberal is going to.
Unidentified: The left and it's not good.
So it's it's that's very bad.
Speaker 4: So that's why I'm here today.
Speaker 1: Crystal clear explanation.
Speaker 2: All right.
Speaker 4: Just support him because he's,
you know, he's fighting for it.
Speaker 6: So what's something that the left
is doing that's super far left?
Speaker 4: Because they they support China
and we don't like China.
You know, China is a communist country, communist
people.
Speaker 1: And by the way, increasingly, China
is not really a communist country.
I mean, they're.
They're run by the party, but it's increasingly
a capitalist.
It's China's complicated, but it certainly
has no connection to reality in terms of what
this woman is saying.
Speaker 4: They spread the you know.
They.
They want to conquer.
They want to.
They want to, you know, to make everybody.
You know, I know now.
Speaker 1: They want to make everybody under
them in the U.S. supports.
Speaker 4: So they.
Because you never been to a communist country?
Speaker 6: I've been to China.
Speaker 4: You've been to China.
And what do you see in China?
What did you see?
What do you see?
Can you tell me?
Speaker 6: I'm curious.
I saw a lot of things, but I'm curious how
this relates to the Democratic Party.
Speaker 5: Oh, man.
Speaker 4: Oh.
Speaker 6: Because Democrat and I think both
the Republican and Democratic Party are pretty
much not communist.
Speaker 4: No, I don't think so.
Speaker 1: Now, she doesn't agree with that.
Wow.
So that's what's going on in America.
That's what's going.
And so when we continue talking about how
do we deprogram, how do we get through?
That's the full scope of what we're up against.
Excellent work by Luke Beasley.
You can find his YouTube channel at David
Pakman dot com slash Luke and let us know
if you want to see Luke at more of these events.
Wow.
I'm going to need to take a break just to
recover from so many high level ideas.
We'll be right back